Speaker 1: let's hear from a few more people
via discord, David Pakman, dot com slash
discord is the place. Let's go to Spencer
from Wyoming. Spencer, you were on the air.
Hi, David. How are you? I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 5: It's an honor to talk to you. I'm glad
you called on me. Thank you. My pleasure.
I just I wanted to bring up the question.
I'm originally from Pennsylvania, OK? And
I lived in a community near Gettysburg. And
we started a petition to rename All the Streets
named after Confederate Generals to Union. OK.
And everyone in the community hated it,
like all the older folks specifically.
And eventually I said, if we could just get one
street sign change, I would call that a win. And
I'm wondering what you think of, you know, we have
a majority in the Senate, House and White House.
But should we be focusing on baby steps or
should we be focusing on what, in my example,
should I have been happy with just one street
change? Or is it is it more important to
really push what you believe to be right?
Speaker 1: Oh, man. This is this I mean,
this is a really tough and big issue. So I
think we should take any winds we can get.
OK, so with the street signs
example, the street names example,
if you want every street name, Confederate street
name changed, but all that can be done because of
the circumstances politically is one that one
is changed. You still take it right, you still
take it. But at the same time you keep pushing
for more. I think for me, the other thing is
I'm all about changing the school names. You know,
I don't want General Robert E. Lee High School or
whatever, and I'm fine with that. But I sometimes
worry that too much energy is going into things
like changing street names or taking down statues
when there are much more substantive issues. I get
that you've got you know, you rectify the language
to try to impact culture. I get the concept of
that. And so calling a calling a street by a
different name can sort of, at a base level,
change how we think about things and think about
history. I also think the left needs to be careful
not to overplay our hand on things like street
names, although we should work on them and we can
walk and chew gum at the same time. But that's
a really complicated question. But to go to,
we should take any wins we can get. Maybe
the only thing that was possible there was
the one one street name, you know.
Speaker 5: Yeah, it was Nathan Bedford
Forrest who watch Forrest Gump is named after
that street, but he lived on it. So we were able
to get that one change. But people were just
you know, they started questioning, you know,
the civil war wasn't even about slavery. It was
it was ugly. But yeah. Yeah, it really made me
question like, should I be happy with that? That
was last summer. I was like, should I be happy
with what we've done here or should I have wanted
more? But I think you you raise some good points.
Speaker 1: You should want
more, but you should be happy
that you were able to get something, I guess. What
was the street name change to out of curiosity?
Was it change like Oak Street or something?
Speaker 5: You know, so all the other streets were
union general, so it actually turned into Lincoln.
We didn't have a Lincoln, believe it or not. OK,
all right. Well, you know, say what
you want about Abe Lincoln, but
better than Confederate General, I would say.
Speaker 1: I would say so. I would say so. All
right. Well, keep on fighting, you know.
Yeah. Thank you. All right. Very good.
OK, let's go next to. Oh, this is it. How about
Elias from Helsinki? You're on the air. Hello.
Hello. Yes, I can.
Speaker 6: Excellent,
congratulations for the brilliant
Speaker 1: views, David. Thank you,
I couldn't have done it without you, Elias.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I've been following you for
I think about seven years or something.
Speaker 1: You're probably good for a
couple of thousand views, I would say.
Speaker 6: I had no doubt. Yeah. So,
yeah, I actually want to ask
you a bit of a more fundamental
question regarding your political views.
Speaker 1: So I have Elias, I know you
said you were in Helsinki. Are you Scottish?
Speaker 6: No, no, no, no, I've finished,
actually. Oh, wow. Yeah, sorry about the
accents. I do have some Scottish friends,
so I suppose they might have a fascinating.
Speaker 1: All right. Go on.
I apologize for interrupting.
Speaker 6: Yeah, no problem. So, yeah,
I think you've said that you are in some sense
in favor of a sort of Nordic model, i.e. sort of
capitalistic system with the socialistic policies.
Well, and then if I describe that correctly.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't call them social.
I don't call it a capitalist system with
socialist policies. The way I describe social
democracy is a socially conscious, well regulated
form of capitalism. That's the way I describe it.
Speaker 6: Yeah, OK, I think that's fair and yeah,
basically, if I'm thinking practically I'm I'm
I would say that's my basically my my basic
political views as well. But if I'm thinking
idealistically, hypothetically myself,
I would actually be much more in favor of actual
actual socialism or communism if that was actually
practical. So obviously, I don't think it's really
that practical. So we don't live in a vacuum. But
if we're just thinking, hypothetically,
would you be in favor of more actual
actual socialistic or communistic policies?
Speaker 1: No, no, I am not a socialist or
a communist. I don't believe that the means of
production should be socially owned. I certainly
don't believe that they should be government
owned. I think that people should be free to
own businesses and determine for themselves sort
of to what degree they want to be entrepreneurs.
I don't believe that the government should
be allocating resources in in most cases,
I'm fine with using market systems
to allocate resources in many cases,
although I think in certain areas things should be
outside of the market. Health care, education. You
know, I've spoken about it before and I also would
not be in favor of a government imposing that the
means of production must be socially owned or
owned by the government. Now, if individual
businesses want to decide for themselves,
we will be a cooperative. I am all for that
100 percent. But no, I would not want to impose
socialism or communism. Those are not my views.
Speaker 6: OK, that's that's a shame.
I think that's unsubscribed for me.
Speaker 1: OK, very good. Well, thank you.
Speaker 3: Alive. I was just
kidding. Just kidding.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Hey, in all seriousness, though,
how late is the sun out in Helsinki right now?
Speaker 6: But right now, I think it's about,
ah, it's it would be sitting
around eight, I know, maybe nine.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's earlier than I
thought Helsinki was far enough north
where you had a very long day and in the summer.
Speaker 6: Yeah, it is, but it's not that bad yet.
Oh, look, it'll be a couple of months before it's
dark at this time.
Speaker 1: I see.
But so wait. When in the middle of December,
when does the sun go down? How early does it set?
Speaker 6: Probably about five or something.
Speaker 1: Oh, wow. It's not that different
than the Northeast. All right. Well, I appreciate
the call. Thanks for clarifying for me. All right,
David. OK, there's a from Helsinki, a
beautiful phone call, I have to tell you.